please ask the panel if they support
abortion based solely on the woman's
rights body then how do they feel if a
woman aborted a specific race
i don't know if anyone said that they
only agree with that
no no i'm it's that's the question so
it's like do you do you support abortion
i mean i personally wouldn't do it
but um
if you want to do it do it it's your
choice yeah
yeah same yeah i think it should be your
choice yeah
yeah i do
no
so
the one thing that so they always talk
about in the u.s that planned parenthood
is
for women like that's like that's one of
the major organizations that support
women but a lot of people don't know
that it was founded by a eugenicist so
the the point of this question is that
80 of planned parenthoods are located
within walking distance of minority
communities in the u.s and the founder
of planned parenthood referred to black
people as weeds that needed to be
exterminated
and that and they're actually doing it
to this day because the black community
in the us has a 50 birth rate and the
black population will be doubled today
if it wasn't for planned parenthood
which is the number one leading provider
of abortions in the u.s
that's crazy so is that something
because on one hand it's like my body my
choice
but on the other hand they're marketing
abortions to minority communities but i
mean
that's a surely a problem with the
institution not women
the number one pro it's the number one
abortion provider in the us yeah the
institution planned parenthood
they're a company with power and
right
so the way that they
run their operation is the problem
not the women who seek out their help
okay what do you guys think
i just
it's a hard one because obviously that's
horrible that's awful but who is going
to look after these kids like say you
know someone's continuously popping out
children
and they're in poverty like who's who's
looking after but remember only eight
percent of women below the poverty line
get an abortion so the majority of
abortions are women that make over forty
seven thousand dollars per year oh yeah
you did that should you say that
um
like i said i think it is horrible and i
think it's awful and i you know i don't
agree with it
being purely because they're black but
again in general well it's not it's not
necessarily like anyone can go in and
get an abortion from planned parenthood
but what they did there was a project
called the n-word project in the u.s
where they specifically might market
abortions to minority communities and
they they use the language of
it's this is affecting women of color
and they'll say things specifically to
market this to minority communities and
it's it's really crazy because margaret
sanger's grandson he's the head of
planned parenthood in new york and he's
still using the same marketing language
to this day
so
like
when when that's the case is that
something we should be concerned about
yeah we should definitely be concerned
about it
and if it's not if it's not a low
if it's not an issue where the kids are
going to be in poverty
well then that's different if the kids
aren't going to be in poverty then
poverty is one thing obviously that's
probably the worst
thing we could you could imagine right a
child coming into the world into right
um although i've had not necessarily why
it's probably well
well well i mean struggling for food
kind of poor poverty i mean you know a
starving child is not a happy child
right
but hey i watched them adverts that
unicef put out and they got children
looking happy in africa and i don't
think that they're well nourished and
they're eating as well as anyone else
here and anyone born in 2022 has a lower
or has a higher standard of living than
most people did in all of human history
again most in all of human history the
majority of people were in poverty like
people are rich today in a historical
perspective
oh yeah i know i know that yeah yeah of
course um i think i think
maybe my point got lost i i didn't mean
that
being born poor is one of the worst
things i i certainly spoke to someone
the other day who said that there was
something about his family coming
together as a unit to get through
certain things which um which obviously
he was very thankful for
but
as a um
just like a like a general rule you
don't want a child coming into a place
where they won't want it or where they
aren't provided or cared for in the best
way possible don't you think that's on
women though to be more selective with
who we sleep with
well or maybe be careful and get on
birth control well well certainly that
that that plays a part but i mean like i
mean again it's like women control
access to sex whilst men control access
to relationships so you sleep before you
won while we sleep with you we can so
the ultimate ultimately sex falls on you
that's why i don't i don't completely
agree with that i think that's that's
how it is so not to push the
responsibility on women that's how it is
because you sleep if you choose to sleep
with so that means if you get pregnant
that is a consequence or a situation
that fails or conscious of your
decisions right so shouldn't you then
make better decisions about who you
sleep with or at least the people you
sleep with should be ready to be fathers
instead of
the statistic where most people who
what she said i think it goes to the
other way around as well
it's it's it's if you're going to say
that about women choosing men you also
need to be the same the other way around
don't get me wrong men need to maintain
discipline
advocate for that but like i said you're
the ones that get pregnant the majority
of the responsibility falls on you your
body changes you're the one who has
personal depression et cetera et cetera
so wouldn't it make more sense to look
after your body yeah i mean
i mean i i would agree with that but
again you know
going back into the whole
life happens right and
sometimes we might know in the back of
our heads something excuse why are we
always trying to give excuses
i think well i don't think it's victim
mentality i think it's it's of course
it's always someone else
no but it's the same way in which for
example men say they don't have emotions
and then get angry right what does that
have to do with it no but
right because because it feeds into the
whole thing right that
we aren't we're animals we're not always
in control of what of what our urges and
what things happen of course we are no
we're not if you're cognizant of the
situation then you can make a choice to
actively do something or not it depends
on your level of self awareness
if you if you have a certain feeling
control there you go yourself but i
think by and large people don't have
that i'm so i'm saying so people are
making excuses and we shouldn't make any
excuses if you do something then be
responsible for your actions i think
that's the main point oh i agree with
that i definitely agree with that so the
whole point is there's always a bailout
for women when we make bad decisions
there's always something bailing us out
it's not the same for men
if they make a bad choice they're on
child support for 18 years we get a
check
or or an abortion like so in this case
we're getting bailed out because we made
poor decisions
men can also walk away like i i know
what you're saying as well but there is
instances like
i know a lot of men that just they just
walk away they don't have to be around
so they're not around well they can't
they can go to jail for that and have
their assets seized yes yes they can
yeah
no yes yes we never knew that yes
i can tell you now majority of people
they don't know that they don't know
that yeah right but the point is that
legally there's a consequence for men
women it's not the same i don't agree
with that i don't agree with that like
you're saying it's the truth but i don't
agree with that i feel like it should be
the same i feel like if a woman pushes
that baby and doesn't want to have
anything to do with it but all of the
man he should be able to take her to
court the same way she can i i agree
wait so you would agree with the
financial abortion then
which is like like so he says when she's
pregnant that
he doesn't want to be a father and he
can just sign off right sign up he does
he doesn't owe anything to her
i think if he said that prior to her
getting pregnant no no after she's
pregnant but so so the same way
well i don't know because all i'm saying
is if you can take a man's call you
should be able to take a woman to court
so
i'm sorry i'm a bit confused as to what
what way we're going here because i'm
just saying like if you have a baby and
the man is going to be on we can go to
court and say you know he needs to be
involved
so i think it should be the same the
other way around if a woman has a baby
give it to the man
right so but i'm talking about if a
woman doesn't want to be a mother she
can she can kill the baby or she can
have an abortion right the fetus
whatever language you want to use but
i'm saying on the other hand a man is
still on the hook for child support
like we're a woman she can even give up
the kid for adoption too that's that's
another option too so if she decides to
keep the baby should she be
entitled to his money essentially
no i'm not saying that exactly i just
think there's it's just it depends on
each situation each situation is
different it's hard to put it all into
one thing because he might said to her
from the get-go you know like i don't
want to have kids if you have this kid
then i don't want to have anything to do
with it yeah like in that situation then
i think at that point that's where she
has the right to choose whatever she
wants
for example if he did want the baby and
now that she's pregnant i don't want the
baby yeah what then i think it's hard
because i think the men should be able
to be involved in those situations as
well what about you eddie as a man
in what sense so like you know
a men and women come together and
they're like you know what let's have a
let's have a child right oh so it's
agreed prayer yeah but then after the
fact he he gets cold feet or whatever
and he's like i don't want i don't want
a baby anymore what then if he's agreed
to that if he's agreed to the fact of a
baby and they've gone in to make a baby
then yeah so that's basically what she's
saying
really i thought she's saying something
different
so what does this mean
if it's a girl i don't i don't think
you're entitled to child support why are
you entitled to his money you can get a
job
i'm not saying you're entitled to it but
that's that's what it is child support
means you are entitled to his money no
the child is entitled right but but the
mother gets the money
yeah but see this is this is what really
pisses me off you know you get a lot of
men and they're like you know i'm not
giving you the money so you can go out
and do this and do that i know there's
women out there that do that they're
swimming they'll go and get their nails
done they won't buy for their kids they
won't do for their kids and i get that
100 but then there's also a lot of
mothers that all of that money goes into
their children but then don't you think
you should be more selective with who
you sleep with like again it's absolving
women of responsibility so that you
picked the guy if you wouldn't make a
good father you shouldn't have been
sleeping with him no it's but like i
said he thought both ways like when a
man's like this woman's trash she's
taken she's not letting me see my child
and you should have thought about that
before you got pregnant do you know what
i mean it does work both ways and also
but also the the only other one thing i
think like well look well the courts
should be even
it should be and right now they heavily
favor women over men you know i agree
with you and i don't agree but i can't
change them do you know but but i'm
saying like why don't we just get the
government out of child support like why
don't we just not have it so nobody's
entitled to anyone's money and we're all
just responsible for the decisions we
make
men and
not get pregnant because they know that
there's no financial backings or
consequences of that pregnancy i don't
know a lot more people make better
decisions but i mean what's the
statistics on women only getting
pregnant just for money what are the
statistics on that like do you have
statistics from that because oh god how
would you get that but that's what i
mean how would you know because a lot of
women don't just do it for that i mean i
i think when you're having
the nba issue reports to all of
that was exactly right no but i'm saying
i'm saying okay
if that's that's a whole group of men
that it's happening to and that's the
number one way nba players go broke so
i'm saying if it's happening to the top
top top men how many men is this
happening to yeah and i'm saying
less than at the top because the top
you're right you're right it's probably
less than at the top but the point is
that shouldn't be legal to begin with
which is why i advocate for getting rid
of child support but these men because
all this money should also be a lot more
careful with who they lay down with but
the but we're going back to women are
stealing their condoms that's very good
so that's not the majority yeah i don't
think that's the majority then why is
the nba issuing a statement warning it's
a
player
mba is
no no i i think that that is common
amongst men of that status and income
but they allow the women in these men go
out and they prey on these young girls
maybe not pray but but no in a sense
they can because you can go to a club
you're an mba player you know you can
have any female in there that you want
they are throwing themselves yeah but
that's not praying okay maybe we're not
praying all right sorry i say get back
wrong choice of words they can go out
and they can have any woman they want
they will choose these women that are
all up on their thing they're taking
their free drink they're going at you
know what i mean they take they're using
their money there and then in front of
them they know what these women are
about they're then taking them back to
hotels and sleeping with them
and at that point i'm not saying it
gives them the right to steal the condom
but you've brought her back you've
brought this woman back
can i make a point can i make a point
he's doing everything right but can i
make a man a man's allowed to sleep
around if he's if he's in the top wait
if he's in the top one percent of men
he's allowed to sleep around why would i
sleep around but if you don't want her
to steal you can't if you don't want to
steal the condom like be careful be more
selective with who you're taking yeah
again it's lame shifting but holding you
it will because it's for both i'm not
saying it's just men it's women and men
everyone should be more celebrated but
no but i was saying if you meant that
like then you would get rid of abortion
for women be more selective with who you
sleep with you could say the same thing
but like i said but like everyone said
abortion is not always that cut okay
sometimes take out take out the one
percent take out the that take it don't
talk about the exception we're talking
about the rule if okay is that the case
we were talking about how you talk about
the nba players right now this is the
one instance in which men are at the at
the um
level let's say to be picking their
women
in these situations we're talking about
here it's the men because they have the
status and the power picking their women
therefore
you can say that women overall pick
their men
when the man doesn't have a huge amount
of status and power but when he has
status and power he picks well you get
you also get predatory women
yeah but predatory women practically men
are two different things two different
beasts and men men
as much as we as the women
so what's the difference the different
the difference is the the general
strength and power that men over have
over women it's you know we can say men
abuse women fine but
women die at a much higher rate under
the hands of men than men do under women
even if the statistics aren't completely
correct which i would agree with
there's still a huge disparity
something like something like already
this year 60 women killed by their
husbands and
sons in domestic abuse
scenarios where where there's been like
three men three the other way around
well
men are more likely to be victims of a
violent crime so men are killed by men
too no that's fair to say but we're
talking about men and women we're
talking about the men and women
relationships we're not talking about
mental men violence i thought we were
talking about predatory men but it's not
the majority of men
okay sorry did you have something yeah i
just want to take it back a step because
eddie you touched a lot on um
women choose who they
sleep with and all of that so when we're
talking about the one percent the men
that do the choosing let's say the men
with the highest status you're saying
they still don't choose no they choose
that they choose a higher rate
but they still it's not all women don't
sleep with them i'm just going to go
back because
i don't have any
i don't know examples of here in the uk
so let's go back to the us right in the
u.s there's i don't know um what they're
actually called but there's this podcast
and there's about three girls four girls
don't know their names one of them was
going on about how she literally let the
whole football team basketball team run
training
exactly everyone knows what we're
talking about
please note that high status men are
still sleeping with these women when you
know what they're about when you know
what they're after you're still going
there
so but we could say the same thing like
you're still sleeping with men when you
know what they're about you know they
would be bad fathers but you're still
going there a hundred percent so
no but i'm saying but but there's a fail
safe for women that's the whole point is
that women get bailed out men don't
that's why the number one reason why nba
players go broke is they get the wrong
girl pregnant so there's a there's a
there's a safeguard for women if i make
a bad decision i can go get an abortion
or i can have the kid get on child
support or i can have the kid and give
it up for adoption but men don't get
that same
out plus in that example you don't think
that those women they're actively
seeking out nba players they said it
themselves that they [ __ ] the whole
team that's what she was looking for
so don't get me wrong there's always an
element of responsibility and that's why
i say men need to maintain discipline
but men are men men are dogs like
if they see her how they're going to put
their willy in it so if these girls are
actively seeking out these men
it's still the women
kind of putting it on these men because
like again
even men at the top women still turn
them down they just have a higher
success rate but women still turn them
down so it's still a similar thing
um
yeah they do but then they still take
home the ratchet ones
where men are men in it yeah
you know and that ratchet one's gonna be
the one that's gonna steal your condom
i don't know if that's the same
situation though
the whole point is there's a fail-safe
women get out of everything men don't
but
what do you suggest that we do for men
what do you use
i did i just suggested it a financial
abortion and that's the only thing
there's nothing else i think that that i
would say that would alleviate a lot of
problems i'd also like to see um should
child support be 50 50. or not child
support sorry custody be 50 50 where
just automatically no matter what unless
there was abuse 50 custody for the man
and the woman i agreed it wouldn't need
to be child support if custody was 50
50. can i add to that so if you're
saying that you agree with men having
financial abortion you give you say oh
financially i'm abortion so then do you
agree with the women with the woman
going to also have an abortion or no
no that's that's what we're saying so if
they're able to do that then men should
also be able to have financial abortion
so do the men see these kids that so the
men that have a financial abortion is it
is it because they don't want anything
to do with this child they don't want to
see the child or the financial abortion
isn't actually a thing it's more of a
scenario like if if women are if it's my
body my choice so they should be like my
money my choice yeah but i'm just saying
like but you know i mean i'd get that if
you like you said if everyone had 50 50.
and then you're taking the child and you
know you're caring for the child and
you're buying the child clothes and
doing your thing then i there would be
no need for childbirth 100
100
but they're not going to do that are
they in the ideal world